foreign
this is their new normal camped out
under the shadow of the offices for the
International Organization for migration
living in a constant state of appeal
a Crackdown spurred on by comments from
tunisia's president targeting
sub-Saharan African migrants has left
many of them homeless and jobless
and desperate to leave
how pregnant are you Fanta I'm a seven
month fans not now okay how are you
feeling
um
when are you expected to give birth
in 10 weeks time 10 weeks time yes all I
need now is evacuation I want to leave
this country because I'm not feeling
safe in this County I don't want my wife
to give back in this place
and just down the road another camp
this is a sit-in in front of the unhcr
offices here in Tunis the people here
are Asylum Seekers they have the ID
cards that make them eligible for all
the protections refugees should have
here under the Geneva Convention but
they're not getting anything and they're
saying that the spike in hate crime has
them wanting to leave as soon as
possible
since the president's decree the racism
is just too much she says they called me
filth
tunisia's foreign minister insists their
measures in place to protect sub-Saharan
African migrants in the country how are
they being protected sir what's what's
in place to protect them I think at all
levels I mean at all levels again the
our authorities uh even for those who
have been who could have been I mean
harmed or anything or threatened this
can happen in every country I mean we
were as Authority we were not
responsible for what what person was
doing I mean you know that many
individuals
could have take this opportunity in
order to to to to to to you know to to
act badly this can happen everywhere
there's currently no National Asylum law
in Tunisia thousands of undocumented
migrants have been arrested in recent
weeks these two brothers from Nigeria
have just been released from prison
everything they took it I let this song
behind me witness I've not seen such a
thing I've never experienced such a
thing in my life how is it like for you
in prison it was him because they were
not taking care of for us nothing
nothing just punishing us acting like we
are slaves or whatever I don't know how
are they punishing you
because they were just treating us
anyhow like the blacks they will not be
caring for us
[Music]
despite the division a sense of
community prevails but some damage
cannot be undone even if the bringing
solution towards this problem the best
solution for me is to leave this country
because it can happen at any time
the only appeal left now is one to God
prayer for a final place of Refuge
Sky News Tunis